Okay, let's address something head on just
to do it and get it out of the way for future
segments last week and in other segments,
I've made an effort to remind the audience
that I'm completely fine covering instances
of right wing violence based on politics,
end of left wing political violence.
And that we shouldn't be hypocrites, we shouldn't
hide left wing violence to the extent that
it exists, but when I do those stories, I
will remind you that it's important to remember
that most politically oriented violence in
the United States is right wing.
It's important to remind you of that, not
for some kind of what about ism, but because
if we really want to deal with the issue of
political violence as an apparatus in the
United States as a problem, we have to understand
where it comes from and it mostly comes from
the right.
Most religious violence in the United States
is from right-wingers, so let's actually dig
into that.
And the way we know things is through studying
data and there are countless ways that you
can come to the same conclusion.
So let's go through some of the sources.
I'm sure many of you will have problems with
some of these sources, which is why I'm presenting
a number of different ones.
Let's start with the anti-defamation league.
The Anti Defamation League has studied this
for a very long time.
Their latest report is from 2018 which makes
sense since we're in 2019 right now and it
is on domestic extremist murder.
50 of 50 people killed in 2018 we're because
of right wing extremism.
78% were white supremacists, 16% were anti-government
extremists, 4% were in cell extremists and
2% meaning one guy was an Islamist extremist.
Now we can argue over whether Islamist extremism
is left or right wing.
The right loves to say Islamist extremism
is left wing because Muslims I guess often
don't like Republicans.
This is extraordinarily simplistic and shortsighted
religious belief to a degree that you become
radicalized, uh, is by nature a right wing
perversion of religion.
But we can ignore it and we can say 49 of
50, 2018 domestic extremist murders.
We're definitely right wing extremists.
One out of 50.
I guess we can debate, uh, uh, the, the specifics
of it, that's the anti-defamation league.
Now I know some of you disliked the ADL or
you don't trust the ADL.
So let's go to another set of data.
This CSI s the Center for Strategic and International
Studies.
They've identified that indeed the overwhelming
majority of violence from extremists in the
United States is coming from white supremacists
and high government extremists, including
militias and so-called sovereign citizens
groups.
Very, very clear on the data.
Some of you will say, David, I don't like
the ADL and I don't like CSI.
Yes, well then you've got the data from the
Center for investigative reporting who also
looked at this from 2008 to 2016 and they
found 115 right wing terror incidents, 63
Islamist inspired terror incidents and 19
left wing incidents.
So if you include radical Islam as right wing,
which I do, it is almost 91% right wing.
If you consider Islamic terror it's own thing,
it's still about 60% right wing.
And bear in mind that this includes a way
broader definition of domestic terror than
any of the other studies.
What if you don't like any of these three
studies?
Well then you can look at the national consortium
for the study of terrorism and responses to
terrorism.
They maintain profiles of individual radicalization
in the United States.
They look at individuals radicalized since
1948 and they have found that 40% are far
right.
24% were Islamist, 17% are far left, and 18%
are what are called single issue individuals
who could be anywhere on the political spectrum
or even sort of outside of it.
So no matter how you want to catalog this,
no matter what set of data you look at when
you look at radicalization in the United States,
when you look at what movements are leading
people to commit violence in order to try
to achieve their political goals, goals, or
enforce what they see as their vision of what
the United States is or should be, it is at
minimum a clear plurality, right wing.
And in some ways when we're looking at, for
example, extremist murders, uh, we're talking
about 90 plus percent right wing.
The normal responses that I hear when I talk
about this.
Well, they're not really right wing.
Uh, and this is a sort of a no true Scotsman
fallacy sort of thing, which we could delve
into a but listen, I mean these militia groups
are right wing white nationalism is right
wing sovereign citizens movement is right
wing extreme dogmatic religious belief that
leads you to violence because you're angry
that other people don't follow your religion,
whether that's Christianity or Judaism or
Islam, that is also right wing by any common
sense interpretation of what we're talking
about here.
Uh, so that one is a common talking point.
You'll hear they're not really right wing
hard to talk to people who are going to make
that argument.
What about Antifa right?
But ANTIFA is a common one that you hear.
Uh, look at the data.
Big Picture.
ANTIFA is tiny.
I am not a fan of Antifa.
I have denounced anti a methods to the extent
that Antifa is a, a sort of coherent and discrete
group with methods.
I'm against all of the stuff that has been
reported under the guise of Antifa.
ANTIFA is tiny.
These are the broader numbers.
You can't look at anecdotes.
Both sides do.
It is another common one that you will hear
where that's why we're looking at the data
to point out that yes, both sides do it in
drastically different proportion and two d
drastically different degrees.
So we've got to take the narrative back.
We don't have to be afraid of talking about
a guy who attempted to fire bomb an ice facility
where no one died or was even injured.
We denounce it.
Uh, we criticize it.
We point out that that person should be prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law, but we don't
lose the narrative.
The big picture narrative that most political
violence in the United States is coming from
the right.
Do you have other data that contradicts all
four of these sets of data?
Let me know.
I'm on Twitter at the pacman and the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show